who we believe we believe  we're still waiting on confirmation that  he said  they're in trouble let's see if we can  try and  confirm that story as jimmy butler joins  us live here at courtside  mr butler what say you  uh i did say that but he said it to me  at the end of the  first quarter that's the only is why i  said it so lebron said to you  at the end of the first day he was in  trouble right so i just returned the  favor  and what does that translate to moving  forward  um we're gonna have to be even better  than we were tonight in order to even  this thing up two to two we realized  that  um so to the film room uh we'll  fix some things come back ready to go